Google's first VR headset was just a
piece of cardboard this is better this
is called the daydream view and it's the
first of probably many viewers for
virtual reality that are going to
support this new breed of Android phones
that's coming out so it's really two
pieces versus the controller which is
this little pebble of a thing that has a
clicky trackpad and two buttons but it's
mostly a motion controller so you can
use it to slash or swipe or point at
stuff and it's this is really how you do
everything in savor that set is much
simpler
really it's just a headset it has some
technology so that when you put your
phone in it uses NFC to automatically
pair and will instantly launch you into
the daydream home where usually we are
things it also works to automatically
align it but the biggest thing it is is
just comfortable it's really light and
sort of plushie and smushy and the whole
goal was to make it feel like clothing
not like a gadget so when you put it on
I mean you still look ridiculous but it
feels better and it feels more natural
somehow Google's whole planets make PR
field
accessible and that's about making it
easy to wear and inexpensive this thing
only $80 and about making it feel
comfortable and nice not like a gadget
the daydream view goes a long way